ارتفاع الحالات المرضيه المرتبطه بفصل
الشتاء يزيد من ازمه الخدمات الصحيه في
المستشفيات ما قد يوافقم من توفير الرعايه
الصحيه ويعرض حياه الناس لخطر اسوا ما كان
عليه في ذروه جائه كورونا تحذير اطلقه
المسؤولون في قطاع الصحه
المقبل بانه عام اصعب من العام المنصرم
شهر يناير هو اصعب الاشهر في الصحه
ليومين سيزيد من الضرر والمخاطر على الصحه
العامه
مورس على خلفيه هذا التحذيري ومخوف من ان
تزيد عوده التلاميذ الى المدارس الضغط على
النظام الصحي اصدرت وكاله الامن الصحيح في
بريطانيا نصائح بابقاء من يعاني من حمى في
المنزل لتجنب اصابه الاخرين وارتداء
كمامات في حال الاضطرار الى الخروج وتجنب
خدمات الصحه الا في الظروف القصوى بسبب
التزايد اعداد مرضى المستشفيات
بالانفلونزا وكرونا والحمى القرمزيه التي
وصلت الى ما يقارب 10,000 مريض هذا الى
جانب اوقات الانتظار الطويله التي قد تؤدي
الى وفاه خمس مئه شخص في الاسبوع بسبب
التاخير في رعايه الطوارئ بحسب الكليه
الملكيه للطب الطوارئ
الحجر الشديد عندما تنظر الى ارقام
الوفيات الزائده واذا عقدنا مقارنه دوليه
سنجد ان العديد من الانظمه الصحيه بعد
خروجها من جائ اذكرونا تشهد معدلات وفايات
اعلى من ما تتوقعه تقليديا وهذا هو الحال
في المانيا وايطاليا واسبانيا
تحذير مسؤولي الصحه يعكس الضغط الكبير في
الخطوط الاماميه لقطاع الصحه قبل جائحه
كورونا والذي يعاني من نقص في كوادره
وقائمه انتظار وصلت لاول مره الى سبعه
ملايين مريض
لم يسبق لهيئه الخدمات الصحيه في بريطانيا
ان عاشت ازمه مماثله لمده ثانيه القرن
الماضي بالرغم من ضخم الملياراته في قطاع
الصحه ولا يبدو حل مشاكله في المستقبل
المنظور لملئ الوظائف الشاغره وتقليس
قوائم الانتظار الطويله مصطفى زاروا
العربيه